mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir un collaro show un peu perturbé
ce soir car le directeur d'antenne de
monsieur maurice le pont nous a confié
la garde de ses deux charmants neveu
cédric et romain série que l'on me assez
voilà mettez vous ici voilà assis devant
moi vous savez je vous donnais des
enfants c'est gentil c'est charmant et
vous crier dessus il n'y aa plus sur ma
chaise
beyou au fait j'espère qu'il va être
atteint mais qu'est ce qu'il fait
[Musique]
le toit allez vous garder notre sang
froid parce que sinon santander
heureusement nous avons engagé une nurse
pour s'occuper ces deux charmants
bambins
madame s'il vous plaît vous occuper des
enfants oui ou non mais non voilà je ne
vous présente même pas nos amis et de
village people
il était déjà avec nous à 19h45 et à la
fin de l'émission ils vont nous chanter
une de leurs nouvelles chansons
vous savez qu'en france on essaye de
faire quelque chose tout de suite on est
limité 1 vous vous avez un groupe
français qui essayent de vous imiter
il s'appelle village popol à face à
village oui propos pourquoi ne portent
pas pourquoi pour la torche demandé à
jacques chancel
en attendant voici village popol in the
navet
[Musique]
il avait il y a plein de vitamines in
l'arrêt quand on a mal géré la bonne
mine
ils ne l'avaient cherbourg et de
protéines est narrée c'est par là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]